viele von euch fragen mich wann eine
neue folge kommt und ja ich weiß ich hab
immer nicht so regelmäßig hochgeladen
wie ich gleich viele von euch gewünscht
hätten aber das lag daran dass die
animationen und die bilder dafür so
aufwendig sind für das format das ist
einfach auch nicht häufiger gehen jetzt
kann man aber schon seit über drei
monaten keine neue folge und das hat
zwei gründe nummer 1 im januar bin ich
aus meiner alten wohnung ausgezogen und
in meinem neuen wg zimmer hatte ich
nicht mal ein schreibtisch an dem ich
arbeiten konnte das hat für mich einfach
so schwer gemacht ein neues trikot
produziert und jetzt kommt der zweite
grund ihr hattet ihr auf den titel schon
herauslesen können mein nachbar hat mein
tagebuch geklaut was wie ein schlechter
witz klingt ist wirklich keiner um zu
verstehen warum er das getan hat ryan
gander und zurück in die vergangenheit
in die zeit in der meine mitbewohnerin
und ich gerade und eine einweihungsparty
vorbereitet habe das war an einem
samstag und er war gerade dabei die
wohnung aufzuräumen und in meinem zimmer
stand noch eine kiste mit kram der noch
keinen platz hatte also haben wir die
kiste zusammen mit anderen machen eine
etage höher in den hausflur getragen
weil wir im vierten stock wohnen wo
inhalt über uns keine menschen mehr da
ist halt leer und einfach nur eine
treppe hoch und anders werden nach ein
paar tagen habe ich die kisten wieder
runter getragen und da ist mir dann
aufgefallen dass sie ein bisschen
leichter sind und jetzt haben auch ganz
schön viele sachen daraus gefehlt ich
habe die nachbarn neben uns gefragt ob
wir so auf dem kasten raus genommen
haben und die meinten nur das war
bestimmt der aus dem zweiten stock der
schlägen da oben manchmal der schnee ja
es hat sich also rausgestellt dass in
unserem haus ein alter verrückter mann
lebt der nicht nur oben in unserem haus
fuß lebt irgendwelche fremden küsten
ausräumt und habe mich ja fünfjährigen
mitnimmt nein seit tagen machte so
komische sachen wie einen farbeimer in
unserem haus für auftippen sein
aschenbecher über die ganze treppe
entleeren und den staubsaugerbeutel
überall einfach im hausmüll verteilt und
für mich erscheint und plastikmüll
kleine verbrochen glasflasche also der
verbreitet sich die ganze zeit schon
also seit tagen der tagung ist einfach
nur chaos im hausflur und ich bin ganz
ehrlich zu euch ich trau mich nicht an
seiner tür zu klopfen
was soll ich denn sagen entschuldigung
wir haben mein tagebuch geklaut
unmöglich würde das gerne wiederhaben
ja man macht mir wirklich an
ich kann mich noch daran erinnern dass
bei unserem eindruck mal in unserer
wohnung völlig random stand und glaubt
mir der sind gewöhnlich auch wirklich
gruselig aber eine gute sache hatte das
ja ich konnte endlich eine story teil
machen wenn es irgendwelche neuigkeiten
zu meinem tagebuch gibt dann werde ich
euch auf jeden fall bescheid geben
ansonsten wenn ich das wiederbekomme
seht ihr ja beim nächsten stopp zu sagen
wünsche ich euch einen schönen sommer
park war mit 1 und kalte pizza und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten video
wieder was ein sommerloch
freut euch drauf ich freue mich auf
jeden fall drauf ich habe jetzt schon
wieder die hater ja die haben keinen
bock mehr tage buchen zu machen
[Musik]